now it's very interesting that there's a
lot of corruption in the olive oil
business it's been going on for a very
very long time so you want to make sure
when you buy olive oil you're getting
the right stuff now
i've been consuming probably a
counterfeit olive oil
for years because
it wasn't until recently that i went to
italy
and actually tasted real olive oil that
i knew
the difference between the counterfeit
and real olive oil and
oh my goodness when you have authentic
real
olive oil it is so delicious
it's a very green bright peppery grassy
fresh taste and all these years i had no
idea
that olive oil was supposed to taste
like this i was consuming
the flavorless and rancid olive oil
which actually had
barely any flavor and i thought that's
what olive oil should taste like
well that was because a lot of companies
were blending the olive oil with a
cheaper low quality oil and only until
recently
is the fda going after some of these
counterfeits
so here are some general rules i'm going
to talk about first thing is i would not
go after the large brands that you would
buy in the grocery store
simply because you don't really know if
it's legitimate
and ideally if you can go to a specialty
store
that you can sample the olive oil that
would be
the best now there's a couple things
that you want to look at
you would want to always get the extra
virgin olive oil
not just the virgin oil um not the
light or the pure
but this doesn't necessarily always
guarantee
that it's the real deal but it's going
to help you
narrow it down number two it'd be good
to find the harvest date
not best by this date or
bottled on this date because what these
companies
do is they take olive oil and they ship
it around the world
and they bottle it somewhere else after
they combine
other oils so we're not interested in
this date we want the harvest date
or processed on this specific date would
be good to have a third party seal
and number four like i just talked about
buying your olive oil from a specialty
store
is probably going to be the best thing
or you can actually
order it right from italy or some other
country that would
you know has the real deal that's what
we did
here's a brand right here that is
seriously fresh okay i mean the taste is
incredible
uh unfortunately i go through this
pretty fast
but you can see that it has pretty much
all the things that i talked about right
here
and it's empty i need to order more and
ideally you want the name of the
producer
or the estate where that olive oil was
originated from now i did put some links
down below of
some good authentic brands that are
legitimate
you can check it out and thanks for
watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto absolutely not karen
and it's an immune system builder
absolutely
you have to check this out i think you
should hurry up watch the recipe
and make it yourself it's just so easy
to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it